.
>> WELCOME TUCKER.
THANK HEAVEN IT IS FRIDAY.
YESTERDAY WAS THURSDAY.
DATA WILL LIVE IN SHAME IN
HISTORY OF THE AMERICAN NICE
BUS.
YESTERDAY PLANT NIGHT EVERY NEW
NETWORK IN THIS COUNTRY BUT IN
ONE, SURRENDER DID HITS ENTIRE
PRIME TIME LINE UP TO NANCY
PELOSI.
SO IN PLACE OF NEWS COVERAGE
PEOPLE COULD TUNE IN GOT TWO
STRAIGHT HOURS OF UNEDITED
CAMPAIGN PROPAGANDA.
BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
EVERY CHALLENGE SAME.
NOTHING LIKE THIS EVER HAPPENED
IN THIS COUNTRY.
NOW NEWS ANCHOR DISSLOWING FOR
HALF.
OTHER SIDE CAN SPEAK.
EVIDENCE IS PRESENTED, AND
EVIDENCE NOT CENSORED OR EDITED.
SO WHAT WE SAW LAST NIGHT WAS
NOT HEARING IT WAS A SHOW TRIAL.
THERE WITH A NO PRETENSE EVER
FAIRNESS OR CAC RAT SEE.
THE WHOLE THING WAS CONVINCED BY
WHAT THEY SAW LAST NIGHT?
RIGHT AROUND 0.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO WIN SINGLE
VOTE SO WHY DID THEY DO IT?
THERE HAD TO BE A REASON.
WELL REASON THEY DID EVERY
MINUTE NEWS ANCHORS ARE WINDING
BUT SOME IMAGINERY FROM EVERY
MINUTE THEY ARE DOING THEY THEY
ARE NOT COVERING COLLAPSE OF
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY
ACTUALLY CARES ABOUT.
FOX I WOULD TODAY, INFLATION HIT
8.6 APIFR THAT'S OFFICIAL
NUMBERS.
THOSE ARE NUMBERS ARRIVED AT
USING GOD'S OWN METRICS BUT
STILL INCREASE INFLATION IN MORE
THAN 40 YEARS NOT SURPRISING
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE DID HE
LOWEST LEVEL EVER REPORTED.
WHY?
REALLY COMES DOWN TO ENERGY.
COST OF ENERGY IS UP NEARLY 40%
OVER LAST YEAR.
AVERAGE PRICE OF GALLON OVER $5.
JP MORGAN PREDICTED IT WILL GET
TO $6 AND SOON.
SO WHEN PRICE OF FUEL GOES UP SO
DOES PRICE OF EVERYTHING ELSE.
BECAUSE TRANSFER STATION SYSTEMS
ARE DEPENDS DENTSZ ON THE PRICE
OF FUEL.
AND WHEN GETS HIGH ENOUGH,
PEOPLE CAN'T GO ANYWHERE.
EVEN THE POLICE IN MICHIGAN ONE
DEPARTMENT SAYS THEY CAN ONLY
RESPONDS TO EMERGENCY CALLS
BECAUSE PRICE OF GAS IS MUCH
HIGHER.
WE EXHAUSTED WHAT FUND WERE
BUDGETED FOR FUEL WITH SEVERAL
MONTH TO GO BEFORE THE BUDGET
RECESS.
QUOTE, I INSTRUCTED DEPUTIES
ATTEMPT TO MANAGE WHATEVER CALLS
ARE ACCEPTABLE OVER THE PHONE.
SO ENFORCING THE LAW OVER THE
PHONE.
SO SOUNDS LIKE STORY FROM THIRD
WORLD.
THAT'S AMERICA.
IT IS MICHIGAN.
AND C NBC SURRENDERED VIEW JUST
FOUND THAT 68% OF CFOS ARE
PREDICTING RECESSION SOON.
0 CFOS SURVEYED BELIEVED
RECESSION COULD BE AVOID ALL OF
THEM THOUGHT IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
INEVITABLE.
WHAT AN OF COURSES?
WELL ONE OF THEM STAPLES FOOT
PRICES THEY WERE ALREADY UP 4%.
NOW UP MORE THAN 10%
YEAR-OVER-YEAR.
YOU HAVE CRISIS.
HOW ADMINISTRATION RESPONDING
THIS CRISIS.
WELL, BIDEN JUST UNVEILED NEW
REGULATIONS ON ETHANOL.
BY THE WAY HERE IS REALLY SIMPLE
TEMPT IF YOU WANT TO KNOW YOU
ARE SPEAKING WITH WHO
UNDERSTANDS ANYTHING ABOUT
SCIENCE OF ENVIRONMENT ANY ONE
TELLS YOU ETHANOL FOR
ENVIRONMENT IGNORANT OR LYING.
WE DON'T AFTER DECADES OF
STUDYING THAT HURTS THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THERE IS NO ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT TO ETHANOL AND THERE
MASSIVE COST.
BOTH TO LAND AND ALSO TO YOU.
THANKS TO BIDEN GOOSE REFINERIES
WILL FORCED TO BLEND $2 BILLION
OF ETHANOL BECAUSE IT IS
RENEWABLE FUEL FOR THE PLANET.
BUT WITH THIS REALLY IS IS IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO BURN FOOD IN
YOUR CAR.
THAT'S WHAT ETHANOL IS.
IT IS CORN.
SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU DIVERT
FOOD CROPS LIKE CORN TO ETHANOL?
WELL WE KNOW THE ANSWER BECAUSE
IT HAS BEEN STUDIED FOUR
DECADES.
IN 2008.
WROTE THIS.
QUOTE, THE USE OF CORN FOR
ETHANOL HAS LED TO MAJOR
INCREASES PRICE OF U.S. BEEF
CHICKEN PORK AND EGGS BREAD
CEREAL MILK.
IN FACT DIRECTOR GENERAL
REPORTS, THEY USING 22 POUNDS OF
CORN FOR EVERY ONE GALLON
ETHANOL ALREADY CAUSING FOOT
SHORT AJTSZ.
WELL OF COURSE THAT WAS 2008
THIS NOT NEWS.
ANY ONE WHO HAS BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION CAN TELL YOU ETHANOL
BAD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT IS TERRIBLE FOR ENGINES.
AND IT IS ABOVE ALL DISASTER FOR
YOUR FOOD SUPPLY.
SO AT THE SAME MOMENT WE ARE
FACING FOOD SHORTAGES BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS DECIDED TO
MAKE FOOD SCARCER AND MORE
EXPENSIVE.
FOOD WILL BE JUST AS EXPENSIVE
AS GASOLINE.
YOU PROBABLY HADN'T HEARD ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN LAST
NIGHT EVERY SINGLE NETWORK IN
COUNTRY EXCEPT OURS WAS
REPORTING ON SOMETHING ELSE.
HERE ARE WILL PRIORITIES.
PRIME TIME PRESENTATION WAS BOTH
CLEAR AND IT WAS COMPELLING.
FIRST HISTORIC SET OF HEARING
HERE THIS NOT JUST ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH OR THE
DAYS LEADING UP TO IT IS ABOUT
CLEAR PRESENT DANGER TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
I HAVE TO SAY JUST HISTORIC.
TO ME.
THIS WAS A HEARING UNLIKE ANY
OTHER.
I THINK THE THEY DID GREAT JOB
TONIGHT.
I THOUGHT CHINA.
IT WAS VERY POWERFUL VERY WELL
PRODUCED IF YOU WILL, TWO-HOUR
PRESENTATION.
JANUARY COMMITTEE CONCLUDES
FIRST OF SERIES PUBLIC HEARINGS.
AND POINT WAS CLEAR.
OUR DEMOCRACY REMAINS IN DANGER.
>>.
THESE PEOPLE.
NORMALLY YOU COULD JUST SAY WELL
THEY ARE DUMB THAT'S WHY THEY
ARE ON TV FIRST PLACE READING
SCRIPTS THAT SOMEBODY ELSE
WROTE.
REALLY LIKE ANCHOR MAN IF YOU
WANT TO BE TOTALLY HONEST ABOUT.
READING WORDS THEY DON'T
UNDERSTANDS.
THAT'S TRUE.
BUT IN THIS CASE IT IS MORE THAN
IGNORANT IT IS MORE THAN
STUPIDITY.
IT IS COMPLICITY IN A CAMPAIGN
TO FOOL THE PUBLIC.
TO MAKE YOU BELIEVE THAT YOUR
PERSONAL CONCERNS LIKE FACTS YOU
CAN'T BUY FOOD OR DRIVE ANYWHERE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD GAS.
THOSE ARE NOT IMPORTANT.
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS SOME
OTHER THING THAT YOU SHOULD BE
TERRIFIED OFF.
RUSSIA!
.
PUTIN.
IT IS WHITES THEY ARE GOING TO
GET YOU!
ANY ONE WHO WORSE REES ABOUT GAS
PRICE OR CONCERNED HOW TO FEED
HIS OR HER FAMILY GETS LECTURE
THAT ACTUALLY YOU ARE JUST
SELFISH.
THIS PANDEMIC.
REALLY?
OR WHATEVER TALKING POINT IS.
WATCH.
>> THERE SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO
HAPPEN TO RAN ATTACK ON CAPITAL.
TO AN ATTACK ON DEMOCRACY TO
HAVE PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
THAT HE WON ELECTION WHEN HE
DIDN'T I THINK THAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAN ANYTHING IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A FUNCTIONING
DEMOCRACY, THEN IT DOES NOT
MATTER IF YOU HAVE A PENNY GAS
PRICES.
YOU DON'T HAVE FINING DEMOCRACY
THEN PEOPLE WILL THINK WHAT DOES
THIS MATTER.
OKAY FINE WE LET GO GAS PRICES.
WHAT DO THIS MEAN FOR INDMRAGS.
WE TALK ABOUT THAT ALL OF THE
TIME.
WHAT THIS MEANS FOR OUR DEMOCRAT
MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT'S WHAT
WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON.
>> TELL US ABOUT DEMOCRACY?
WHAT IS IT?
SUM IT UP FOR US YOU.
DETERMINE YOU USE A LOT WHAT
DEMOCRACY IS PROCESS BY WHICH
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTS VOTE
REMEMBERS AND THEIR CONCERNS.
VOTER REPRESENTATIVE THEY GO TO
WASHINGTON AND THEY CARRY WITH
THEM IN THEIR HEARTS THE
MEMORIES OF PEOPLE WHO PUT THEM
THERE AND THEIR CONCERNS.
SO WHAT ARE FIRST FOR MOMENT
CONCERNS OF AMERICAN VOTERS
PEOPLE AT THE HEART OF THIS
DEMOCRACY.
WELL, GAS PRICES.
PEOPLE WERE DEFENDING DEMOCRACY.
LOOK AT THOSE PEOPLE SAYING SHUT
UP YOURSELFISH R BUT ABOUT.
YOU SHOULD REALLY CARE ABOUT
JOHN 6TH BECAUSE DEMOCRAT SOME
YOU AMERICANS DON'T CARE ABOUT
JANUARY 6TH.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY NEED TO BEAT
YOU IN FACE AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
THEY WOULDN'T BE REPETITIVE AND
PATRONIZING IF YOU ACTUALLY
CARED.
SO THIS IS BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
STRATEGY.
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
SHAME YOU IF YOU DON'T THINK IT
IS MOST IMPORTANT THING.
SO BIDEN BEGAN TALKING THIS
SPEECH THAT BUILT -- BUT IT
DIDN'T BEGIN WITH INDMRAGS OUR
ANY HONEST ACCOUNT OF HOW WE GOT
HERE AND HOW WE ARE GOING TO GET
OUT OF IT.
NO.
WATCH.
>> BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT TO SAY
FEW WORDS VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
JANUARY 6TH HEARINGS THAT WERE
HIGHLIGHTED LAST NIGHT.
ON JANUARY 6TH ONE DARKEST
CHAPTERS IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY
BRUTAL ASSAULT ON OUR DEMOCRACY.
BRUTAL ATTACK ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SOME LOSING THEIR LIVES.
AND WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT LAST
NIGHT AGAIN.
WE CAN UNITE FINEST NATION
DEMOCRAT ALLOWING NO ONE TO
PLACE DAY DAGGER THEY THROATED
OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> AGAIN, SO RIDICULOUS.
WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON
IN WORLD WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
ON JANUARY 6TH BECAUSE NO EVENT
IN HUMAN HISTORY HAS MORE
CAMERAS TRAINED ON IT.
WHAT GO AHEAD DO IT GET BACK
TOOUS.
BECAUSE THAT LOOK LIKE DAGGER
DEMOCRACY.
IT IS LIKE INSANITY.
WHY DOES HE TALK LIKE THAT.
.
RUSSIA THREAT PING TO DESTROY
NEW YORK CITY WITH NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
SO ARE WE DOING ON THAT FRONT.
WELL TURNS OUT, WE ARE SOURCING
A CRITICAL XOEMENTS IN OUR
AMMUNITION NOT JUST FOLLOWING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS FROM CHINA.
SO MOMENT WE ARE ACTUALLY CLOSER
TO WAR AT NIM TIME IN YOUR
LIFETIME, ANY TIME SINCE 18945,
BIG WAR ENDED WE CLOSER THAN ANY
TIME SINCE THEN.
WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT IT?
WHAT'S STATE DEPARTMENT DOING TO
FIX CRISIS.
WELL THEY HAVE HIRED GLOBAL
EQUITY.
THAT WILL FIX IT.
WHO WAR EQUITY.
THIS NUTS LIKE REARRANGING BOOK
SHELVES BOY TITLE.
THIS MENTAL ILLNESS.
EVERY ONE SIZE SEES HOW FAKE
THIS.
NOBODY CONVINCED BY IT.
IT WAS JUST A TWO YEARS AGO LIVE
ON TELEVISION SUMMER OF 202 MOB
TRIED STORM WHITE HOUSE.
THEY TORCHED A CHURCH.
MOB CALLED PRESIDENT OF UNITED
STATES LYNCH TO UNDERGROUND
BUNKER FOR SAFETY.
WE HAD DOWN PLAY DO THAT TIME.
WE PEARL HARBOR.
THIS WHAT OUR COUNTRY CAPITAL
LOOKED LIKE AT THE TIME.
>>
WAR.
LOOK AT OUR TAPE.
BUT REALLY JUST TOO MUCH.
STOP LYING TO US.
STOP TELLING US THINGS THAT WE
KNOW FOR A FACT THAT ARE NOT
TRUE BECAUSE WE WATCHED THEM IN
REAL TIME.
YOU DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT LAST NIGHT SIMILARLY GOTS
DESTROYED CITIES ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU DIDN'T HEAR SINGLE WORD.
NONE OF THAT WAS DAGGER AT THE
THROAT OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
ALL THAT HAPPENED WITH THE AIM
OF DMRUNSING THE ELECTION.
WE HEARD NOT ONE WORD ABOUT GUY
TRYING ASSASINATE.
SUPREME COURT AS HIS HOME AT THE
USUALING SENATE MAJORITY LEADER.
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT ANY OF
THESE.
THESE TOPIC LIKE FAITH U.S.
ECONOMY ARE OFF THE HOOK.
YOU HAVE PRETEND JANUARY 6TH
REMAINS SINGLE WORST THING EVER
OVER TO HAPPEN TO AMERICA EVEN
THOUGH NOT ONE LIVING PERSON
REALLY MROOEFLS THAT IF YOU
DON'T SAY SO YOU CONFESS TO ONE
TRUE THING FOR PUBLIC.
YOU WILL BE HURT.
JUST HAPPENS WHEN NFL COACH USED
ONE THOSE.
COMPLETELY WE GOT MORE ON THAN
IN JUST A MINUTE FIRST TAKE FEW
STEPS BACK.
SO THIS IS PERVEZ ARRANGE
MINUTE.
YOU GOT TO WONDER WHO BENEFITS.
CONGRESS AND ENTIRETY OF
CORPORATE MEDIA.
BURY ACTUAL PROBLEMS FACING
UNITED STATES.
PRETEND LIKE THEY ARE NOT EVEN
HAPPENING.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS AND WHO
IS